the life of oklahoma prisoner julius
jones was spared just four hours before
he was scheduled to be executed governor
kevin stitt commuted jones's sentence to
life in prison without the possibility
of parole maria vidal has more from
oklahoma city where the case has become
an emotional flash point
julius jones's family rejoiced when
learning he would live what was that
moment like for you
it was a it was a blessing his sister
antoinette was relentless in her fight
to save him i feel lighter just the
realization that
my brother is going to live
jones supporters mostly strangers hugged
cried and chanted his name we were all
in there crying and grateful and jumping
up and down jones was sentenced to death
nearly 20 years ago for murdering paul
howell but his family says eyewitness
descriptions did not match him and they
claim he was home at the time of the
murder i am not the person responsible
for taking mr house
earlier this month the state's pardon
and parole board recommended his death
sentence be commuted pointing to doubts
about evidence in the case
then thursday just hours before jones
was scheduled to be executed governor
kevin stitt filed an executive order
sparing his life with the condition that
he shall never again be eligible to
apply for be considered for or receive
any additional commutation pardon or
parole meaning jones will spend the rest
of his life behind bars
law professor maria kohler says it's an
unusual move it seems to me that a
sitting governor does not have the
constitutional power to
limit
the authority of a future pardoned
parole board or future governor
regarding commutations
paul howell's family says they take
comfort knowing that the governor's
decision affirmed the guilt of julius
jones but antoinette says this will not
stop her from fighting for her brother's
release
together and
come up with a new plan fight is not
over he is an innocent man
even oklahoma's top officials don't
agree on this case the attorney general
writing yesterday a thorough review of
the evidence confirms julius jones's
guilt in this case and the death penalty
is warranted so clearly this is not the
last we've heard of jones case i'd
imagine gail will hear something about
it in the next few years
i think you're absolutely right about
that mariah thank you very much as she
said as the expert said it was very
unusual decision by the governor it
seems both sides have reason to feel
that they were validated in some way
yeah it's a tough decision i think the
phrase is splitting the baby right no
one's happy right and perfect word is
validation and julius jones family they
are saying well thankfully he's not
being executed but then on the flip side
yes look at the victim's family saying
well at least they are affirming that he
is guilty yeah and jones's family is
making it clear they're not done yet